[Music]
it's hot out there
and it's about to get hot in here
because we are talking about the third
of the big h's
[Music]
there's like four of them maybe well
hume is a miner but
hey hegel husserole and heidegger
yeah humans yo kant like [ __ ] hume
backwards so he like hume was out of the
academy until like
i don't know until deluse was writing
yeah until de luz did his like
dissertation on him and
duluth made pragmatism fashionable for
the french nerds
you could always do like hume herodotus
and hemholes or something like that
yeah the minor h's yeah today we're
doing the
today we're doing the major h's yeah
have you guys read hysterol lately i
i remember like getting off on it when i
first was reading it and now it's just
way too freaking boring last time i like
seriously read it was like
20 13 14 when i went through like his
european sciences book
yeah i think i read some i read some
back in my masters in philosophy in like
a reading group
uh yeah yeah that was probably like 2012
or something
i got most of my boring second hand
boring ass writer
he is really boring yeah that's i think
part of the reason i've never gone back
to it
i don't think he's obligated to
entertain us though especially based on
his subject matter
he's not gonna be like he's not gonna be
like here's the subject object division
there's a [ __ ] million different
streaming channels provided with all the
goddamn content that i want
and at least 10 billion forum sites out
there okay
i need something better than like we'll
deduce the transcendental ego
from pure experience i'm sorry
the triangle of the nomad the noetic the
nomadic
and the nuos what if we had what if we
had eric uh eric narrate it and make an
audio book for you of it would that make
it i mean maybe
that could compel me yeah i still have
to read the phenomenology of perception
now we learn about the apple shay
everyone clear your mind
that was before the radio so they didn't
know how to do stuff interesting
yeah yeah true enough the epic key is uh
yeah no i think that was something that
uh matt said was
pawn tate yeah the phenomenology of your
perception
yeah no i'm gonna finish yeah that's the
monster it's cause uh
because hot well i i'm gonna need that
back because i'm gonna do a video on it
what do you need
are you doing a marilyn ponty video with
you
oh yeah okay yeah when did you get back
by
i don't know i'd put all that other
invisible invisible it's more
interesting
put all that reading to work in january
or something yeah oh that's fine i
i was just gonna say it because i was
gonna read one more book and then get to
it so that should be
flesh every philosophy every philosopher
is boring you gotta make them fun
you gotta you gotta be interested in
what they have to say
and then that's not true like [ __ ]
kierkegaard's not boring at all kicker
guards literally like i dumped my wife
here
the reasons why uh and now let me
explain to you why everyone hates me but
they're wrong
and then and then 65 pages on job
which is not exciting that's interesting
because it's just like yeah god
basically just decided like oh this
guy's a really good person
and then satan's like well why don't we
punish him and god's like [ __ ] yeah
let's do it
well the bible's boring as [ __ ] but it's
shaped everything for the last two
thousand years i don't think the
i don't think the bible is not the
the first testament is good the ideas
are fine but when you actually read it
like and thus
spoke mark to matthew that that is
king david went to the philistines
killed like 600 of them and cut their
foreskin and isaac begat
i sock and i sock begat so sock and saw
sock begot brock and brock be got and
then that's like 50 pages later you
finished genesis
what a [ __ ] ride that is boring i'll
give you that but like job is literally
that like it's a fascinating book
because like
it's basically exactly described to
satan goes up to god and basically like
i want to [ __ ] punish this guy
because he's been really good and i want
to show that everyone could fall and
god's like well why not let's run the
experiment
and job complains and he's like why did
you do this to me lord and god
eventually just has no answer for him
except for like
you do what i say you little [ __ ]
punk you know what i mean like who are
you to question me
and then god's like but you know what
you're right like it's a very very weird
story so
all right so welcome to uh the pale pod
oh yeah we're recording we've actually
mentioned a few key terms that define
heidegger's early life kierkegaard and
uh he was training to be a priest i
think
i don't know how many german catholics
there were but he was one of them
there's loads of if i'm not mistaken
yeah this is going off
going out of my memory bank was he was
he catholic he was
i think he was a jesuit no uh he was
trained to be part of the roman catholic
priesthood i'm not sure if he was
training in the jesuit order but his
early research was on
mathematics then he switched to a kind
of scholastic aristotelianism
i would have assumed he's protestant
because that's what germany martin
luther protestants
no uh actually you you could safely
assume that for most but heidegger was
an exception
yeah and actually you kind of see that
also because um
protestant theology at the time people
like paul tillich who was inspired by
like heidegger sometimes has a bit of a
conservative edge to it but it's much
more
willing to embrace elements of modernity
the kind of german catholicism that he
came out of is a lot more
hostile to modernity just wholesale
right and
it never really that attitude never
really left him i think well he seems to
have missed the guilt train too which is
i think yeah
you get like the best place you could
probably go for a philosophy education
throughout a lot of europe was to a
seminary
to be instructed by i don't know
whatever religion religious teachers who
would teach you latin
and greek and how to read the bible and
yeah then
hagel was obviously a seminarian too and
so were a lot of the german idealists
who heidiger tries to
i don't know overcome as they say
so we are biting off a lot and just
seeing how it goes we might have to do
two episodes
on this but heidegger existentialist
phenomenologist hermeneutician
not sure if that's a word um and then
whatever you call
later heidegger did i miss anything nazi
yeah he turns into like a
nazi yeah i think i think we can ignore
that for this episode we've done enough
on that [ __ ]
we're not going to talk about it we can
acknowledge it yeah we can we've already
we've already talked about that plenty i
mean we could all i could say to
heidegger becomes like
some kind of a weird spiritual mystic
kind of in some of his later
work i don't know would agree with that
but that seems like
they call him like the hermit of marburg
or something like that you know well he
never
he never really abandons like his
central project of trying to
understand this question of being that
he comes up with as like this sort of
revolutionary
avenue of inquiry and philosophy to
question just like what is being or as
as as bill clinton put it two two
decades ago
what your definition of is is it depends
upon what the meaning of the word
is yes heidegger was all about what
is is i don't know maybe that's was
maybe that was heidegger's defense where
is you a nazi heidegger well it depends
what is is
were you [ __ ] monica lewinsky
[Laughter]
uh that was brilliant yeah was it
clinton or heidegger who said language
is the house of being
i can't remember the white house of
being i think it was the white house
it's in washington clinton yeah that was
the oval office of being
yeah no that's the circle of the
clearing where
being comes i think that was my favorite
open ever eric that was [ __ ]
you know great
all right so we're gonna have to take
this slow try not to name drop
term not to term drop i guess might be
more important in
in this episode um but we could
we could start with like what's the
import of heidegger
despite him being a nazi yeah yes
he's arguably the most important
philosopher of the 20th century
so he's got that going for him he's he's
one of the votes alongside
wittenstein's logical tractatus for
having one of the most important books
i mean i think those are really the only
two competitors if you look at like
formal philosophy right you might also
be able to throw in
foucault and contention if you're
looking at just like
sheer influence citations all that kind
of stuff well
foucault was a high targaryen he said
apparently according to hubert dreyfus
who is a who is a leading
phenomenologist he said
foucault on his deathbed said his his
whole ubra has been
basically response to heidegger in
and many years like we should need to
return to cancer oh heidegger was it
heidegger was a nietzschean too
was into polyamory when it came to the
history of ideas right you know
it was always like yeah i'm with you
baby uh you know whenever he was with
uh you know in the room with him but he
would change his tune
uh when he was with somebody else
because it's because nietzsche was like
a challenge to all
philosophy before him like like
nietzsche nietzsche is the first guy to
start this like movement of overcoming
the metaphysical tradition and heidegger
saw himself as
like continuing that project so i think
a lot of these new thinkers like derrida
foucault get their interest in nietzsche
in a large part
through heidegger yeah i'd probably say
that's right and the way heidegger uses
nietzsche
and heidegger wrote more on nietzsche
than anybody else
yeah i i don't know massive pretty
impressive massive books
and it was almost exclusively on will to
power
as well which was an unfinished book and
the eternal current
oh you mean the book yeah okay i was
going to say the two big things in those
volumes are will the power and the
eternal recurrence
but in terms of in terms of outgrowth
there is you know how to go the
existentialist
which becomes manifest in french
uh sartre and then in phenomenology with
merlot ponte
with the hermeneutic turn in derrida so
you could say
he kind of inspired the whole or his
many ideas inspired
a whole generation of french thinkers to
pick up and and walk in different
directions and although and of course
being in time right has like early
magnum opus is uh a response
to and like he saw it at the at least
initially as a continuation of
pisceral's work who i think he studied
under um at the university so
so he does start off i mean of course
being the the like
the main the first phenomenologist to
call himself that in the in the sense
that we would mean it today
at least of course there was like hegel
talking about the phenomenology of
spirit but in the sense we would mean it
today
visceral was the first and to some
extent heidegger was trying to continue
that phenomenological tradition that
husserl started but he wanted to focus
the analysis
on a more fundamental ontological
question than being in time which is
like
the question of being ultimately but he
but i think the method he's using in the
book
in being in time is largely inspired by
phenomenology his analysis
of design right which is just another
the word he uses for
um like you know human being or like or
or subjectivity or something like that
dozen is is a
i think largely a phenomenological
method
yeah i think that's a good place to
start but why don't you
uh why don't we start with the
difference between
his oral and heidegger i just wanted to
invoke to point out like
as a matter of like technical
clarification he actually dedicated uh
the early version of being in time to
husserl
um uh he withdrew the dedication
actually during the nazi era because
herself was jewish
uh took a lot of flack for that uh
although he apologized for it by saying
well
there are still references to hersely
and phenomenology through the footnotes
that were kind of of course because
israel was jewish
yeah exactly um but apparently it broke
the old man's heart right like crystal
was really sad since he considered
potager to be his kind of
protege going out there carrying on the
project uh and when
you broke with him right through nazism
yeah i've got it right here actually in
this translation the stonebow
translation the uh this one with the
leaves on it
yeah it does say uh dedicated to edmund
herself in admiration and friendship
april 8th to 1926. yeah well
it was reinstalled uh or sorry restored
after uh
you know the the nazi revolution right
um
probably wise actually so there's a lot
of terms that came up there
yeah like fundamental ontology
i mean the difference let's go for the
difference between heidegger and husserl
the easiest way to
talk about it is that uh
husserl could be called a descriptive
phenomenologist whereas heidegger would
be classified as a hermeneutic
phenomenologist
so husserl's idea was well phenomenology
for him was in the surface of science
right so to help scientists
describe the worlds in a more attentive
and minute kind of way which would then
help them
out like i'm not again i'm not a big
husserl scholar i don't think any of us
are
but heidegger came in with hermeneutics
because
he's all about the meaning of being
right so you'll see
things like the question of the meaning
of being all over his work
and that's because it's interpretive
work and what is hermeneutics
well that evolved out of the biblical
tradition so that goes back to his sort
of seminary training it's the biblical
tradition of hermeneutics where you
would figure out ways to interpret the
bible
and he brought hermeneutics into
phenomenology
so that's probably the biggest
difference you can just with terms and
you can see it right in i mean in the in
the table of contents right when it
starts he starts with the question of
the meaning of being right so meaning
obviously is like uh
the starting point right so there's
obviously a hermeneutical starting point
but yeah pills
go ahead your heuristic for
understanding hermeneutics
is the hermeneutic circle which i think
is a term that you may have heard before
but it it just means that the reader has
like a a horizon
of meaning a set of understandings that
they get
then they read a text that text
changes their understanding then when
they read that text again
uh there's a circle going on so it's
affective and i think this comes from
schleiermacher because he's talking
about
you know you read the bible and the
bible
and or inspires you to change your view
of the world
but then uh you also
change your reading of of theology or
biblical literature yeah there's a
certain sense of
of interpretation also being sort of
just like a basic thing we do
as well in this like hermeneutic circle
because we have a bunch of assumptions
about reality
which is kind of our like natural
ontology i guess which is given to us in
the way we're
brought up and socialized and common
sense you might call it
well yeah yeah yeah sort of except it's
it's it's common sense
but it's it's a sort of also for
heidegger it's like a lack of
critical reflection as well you just
make all these assumptions so it's like
you know go go out and like try to
just like perform the thought of
experiment of trying to look at
something
and not know it for what it is like go
out look
look at an exit sign and try to just
like not know
already that it's an exit sign directing
you outside
interpretation is so fundamental to our
experience of the world
that he wants to get underneath this
these assumptions we make that go into
our interpretation and try to
open up what he would call i guess
new ontologies like different different
assumptions about what the world is
what it's made of what science tells us
about the worlds
where you know the whole idea of subject
object divide for example
is is an ontological frame that's been
pretty dominant
right up until heidegger is that you
know humans are
subjects and the world appears as
objects opposed to subjects and that's
sort of how so
so you have to sort of get rid of your
biases and your subjective opinions
and you just have to see the world the
way it is objectively
and that's been the sort of i think
that's developed in philosophy
pretty much since since uh since
descartes
since descartes called us says plato in
some ways
yeah yeah descartes in many ways is yeah
obviously he's
pushing this forward into a dualist
ontology
where there's two types of things
there's thinking things
which become subjects and there's
extended things
which aristotle called substances which
we now call
objects and heidegger wants to just get
rid of all of that [ __ ] he thinks it's
all
just hiding more fundamental questions
that we can actually get to
this is actually where i want to bring
up the kind of existential dimension to
his thought and how i think it
links both the hermenonic and
phenomenological elements of the
heideggerian project at least the early
heideggerian
project right so i think that the way
that he kind of distances himself from
pastoral uh
is in two ways right rehearsal kind of
perpetuates this very modernist project
of
trying to look at the rational
conditions for any kind of experience
in the same way that descartes and kent
were trying to do
except that he says that he has a more
accurate way of engaging this
by allowing things to appear as they
really appear
to the conscious ego right and one of
the things that heidegger says right
from the very
beginning of this book which i think is
quite striking is that this presupposes
that the first thing that we do
is engage in conscious activity uh
that's directed rationalistically
towards the world
uh and later on he you know criticizes
this um
by distinguishing between philosophy and
thinking right uh and kind of
philosophical rationalization and our
everyday experience of the world
because he says no you know what's
foundational to dassain
isn't actually rational reason it's
care that's what he calls our structural
primordiality right
and he says the fact that we care about
the world and in fact must care about
the world
is what invest it with a kind of meaning
that opens it up for
various possible interpretations
depending upon what our goals and
ambitions are
right so if i look at a hammer and just
see it as a collection of geometric
shapes
to be analyzed in this euclidean manner
or even in a more materialistic fashion
as
a bit of matter that's composed and
articulated in a certain way
i don't really understand the meaning of
this hammer
as it would appear to somebody who cares
for instance about being a carpenter
which is something he writes about a lot
right who would look at this much more
as a tool to be used in a certain way
because they're invested in a certain
project that gives their life meaning
right and this in the early 20th century
was just a radically innovative way of
thinking about things
uh and it's not just a radically
innovative way of thinking about things
but i think it's a very powerful way of
thinking about things
uh because one of the points that were
made was made
by by herbert dreyfuss right he's like
well look at if you ask yourself you
know
are we beings who think are we beings
who care more the very first act that we
engage in
uh when we come out of the womb is to
cry out signifying the fact that we're
invested in this life um and thrown into
it without any kind of sense or reason
uh given behind this existence right
and that prefigures any of the kind of
conscious rationalizations that we
engage in
yeah it's probably good to note that
he's not using these words in like the
everyday sense too so
care care doesn't really mean
you know just like a sort of effective
attachment to things
it doesn't really mean that for heidi
all right i think the german is bazorgan
but he uses he he tries to find a whole
new terminology because
the other problem with metaphysics which
he's trying to get out of
is that all the language has been passed
down to us
and all the language is insufficient so
heidegger needs to come up
either come up with completely new terms
which is part of why
reading him is maddening and translating
him is
ridiculously hard and also he takes old
words and uses them in
very completely completely new ways so
there's there's that double
problem of inventing words and taking
words out of
their traditional sense and just using
them in a totally different way
yeah he reappropriates a bunch of words
and care you're right i think care is a
good example of something that i always
read as
meaning like kind of that there's a
significance to things
like like that that is like a defining
feature that like we're
and it's also um defined like care is
also a name he gives i think to like
that three-fold relationship of what
does ein is in
right so like the fact that dazn is
projected forwards towards its projects
um the fact that dazain is like thrown
into the world
like un unknowingly and the fact that
like um
dozen is always relating to like what
happened before it like there's like
that three-fold
there's like a temporal that's where
like the time part and being in time
comes
comes in right it's like there's that
three-fold
um aspects of dozen which together i
think does define for heidegger dozen as
care projectedness throneness and i
forget what the one is for like
backwards looking but like um
but those things like the fact that
there's an awareness of that that those
things are all
the way dozen orients itself to the
world
is the k is what he means by care uh
as i understand it um if you want
there's a video that i did like six
months ago and explains
each of the each of the terms including
throneness care
in visual form which is sometimes a
little bit
more easy to see so we've done i think
section one and i think it's great
i just want to simplify a little bit if
i can
because one thing that you all said
correctly is that uh
it's hussurl has a little bit of a
mentalist or uh
overly mental cognitivist kind of thing
right of like consciousness so
consciousness and
and he is also trying to get rid of the
divide between subject and object
but he so he has this idea of a
consciousness of so
there's no consciousness in itself
you're always conscious of something
but what care adds to this is like you
can be conscious of something and not
care about it and now i'm using it in
the regular sense of caring
but when something means something to
you that's more than being conscious of
it
so i want to move into the next section
of being in time
here in the design part because as you
said matt with the hammer
if you're a carpenter or or whatever
you're an expert at if you're an expert
at something
especially then a hammer is going to
mean something very different to you
you're not going to see it and be
conscious of it
you're going to incorporate it into your
body almost like it's a part of your
arm you might say the same thing with
like a phone
today or a keyboard today we don't think
about
we're not conscious of the keyboard it
just becomes incorporated
into the way we interact with the world
this is actually where i think it's so
important to actually recognize what
victor was very rightly talking about
which is how it is that
care is translated into temporal terms
and one of the things that
heidegger pushes very stringently
against is the kind of
candy and newtonian idea that time is
experienced by us
linearly right uh as a line because he
sees this as essentially
locating us too much in the present
right um
and even though of course you know there
are certain things that are present at
hand that we need to acknowledge
uh what he says is a question can you
explain the term yeah this is what i'm
getting at right so
basically you just said present at hand
though can you explain it i'm gonna get
you right there
the kind of approach to time that he
takes is uh what he calls ecstatic
uh and this later comes out in an essay
called time and being
right where he says that you know we are
essentially
determined in some ways by the
historical past which allows us to
establish
certain kind of projects in the present
with what's present at hand
the kind of objects that appear to us uh
but of course
these objects only appear to us as what
they're useful for because
the projects that are determined by the
past uh have resonance for us and our
future hopes and expectations
right we have to have something that
we're using these tools for
and so in this sense you know he says we
need to understand time ecstatically
because it's never just a linear moment
a certain a linear experience of
this moment this moment this moment this
moment it's a much more holistic
experience of time that allows things as
they appear to us at the present
uh to shine forth uh as what they are
for us interpretively or hormones have a
significance they have to be and i
remember what the term was like
the backward looking has fallen so like
we're fallen we're thrown and we're
project we're projected forward
and there's an oscillation between all
of these that make our experience
possible
but i do kind of want to back up quickly
because i feel like we maybe missed
something important which is just like
how like the fact that he's
like the way he gets to an analytic of
dozen i think it's just like worth
mentioning
that the way he does that is he starts
right with the question of the meaning
of being
and he decides through a a couple of
steps of reasoning
that the only way to understand what the
meaning of being is is through an
analytic of dozen which is like the
human being
and then so like it starts off as like
the meaning of being but then he kind of
what
gets what seems like sidetracked because
he realizes the only way to answer the
question
is to analyze the thing that the meaning
of being is an issue for which is the
human being
and then that leads him in to then start
analyzing well what's dozy and what is
dazain doing all the time
how is it defined what like how can we
understand its
experience and those are all so i just
want to i just thought it was worth
mentioning to back up that relationship
yeah and that's
that's like realized too that that
phenomenology is not
an a sort of abstract analysis it's kind
of a minut accounting
of our everyday engagement with the
world
like that's the whole idea of
phenomenology for us or
not for husserl for husserl it's for
scientific purposes for heidegger it's
more
you got to go through dazzling's
sort of what i think dreyfus calls uh
um like absorbed coping with the world
the way we
deal with things on a daily basis the
everydayness
every day yeah yeah heidegger calls it
the every everydayness right
yeah that's i think you have to get
through it and that's so fundamental
what's common though to hustle and
heidegger is like
even though like i still think that what
heidegger's doing here at least
is also very descriptive like it's it's
if anything it's excruciatingly
descriptive because he's trying to
describe like the minutia of how
oh like things have an everydayness but
like when you when you describe
underneath that when you like try to
think about what makes that everydayness
possible what makes dazain's experience
possible
you start analyzing all these different
structures by describing them
and you kind of and i think that's what
he's trying to do is like bring to the
foreground
what is actually in the background when
we're kind of you know preoccupied with
our everydayness with our regular
commonsensical experience of the world
and we can see
um that that that what's making that
common sense
structure of our experience of design um
is actually like these structures like
the fallenness the throneness the
project these are the things that i
think for him make it possible to have
that thing
but then that thing that common sensicle
that fo that everydayness distracts us
from the truth of those structures that
make it possible
okay i would know that we're all excited
but i can
hear you guys stalking everyone's
excited i need to
keep jumping in here to because i know
we all know
heidegger really well but i'm not
expecting that everybody listening to us
knows heidegger really well for sure so
if you want a a heuristic again
you can think of who cyril as
thinking of the most abstract
or not it's not even abstract it's just
it's
descriptive in the sense of how does
a mind a consciousness experience
the world but he's thinking as if this
is a scientist
understanding the world and the
scientists already has
you know goals in place and they're kind
of lofty in terms of what the phenomenal
object is the object that appears so
they're already thinking
i guess you could say very rationally
very high-mindedly about their object
but what heidegger wants to make his
philosophy is about
is not how the scientist thinks about
object
we could call this present to hand by
the way if you are familiar with
uh being in time for our words
vocabulary
but he wants to think about instead how
does like
how does a carpenter think about the
world
because they don't think about it
they're not using a scientific
reasoning to think okay how's a hammer
how am i going to like put this building
together
they just know how to do it and it's an
embodied
knowledge already so he's kind of
getting phenomenology out of
conscious mind scientific thought and
putting it into
uh an embodied sense and you can see why
this is really productive for philosophy
later in the 20th century because it's
about everyday objects not about
scientific
objects one of the examples i sometimes
give is actually what i used to give
actually when i was attempting monterrey
is
playing soccer right i mean people might
see playing soccer as be
you know simplistic and you try to
analyze it scientifically by saying like
wow there's certain coordinated
movements that these people making
at a certain velocity and they're
clicking this plastic object and the
wind is going to have this kind of
variable
uh but that's not the way that people
experience it while playing soccer
uh what they actually experience it as
is much more along the kind of ecstatic
lines
uh that heidegger's talking about right
where they're thinking
this is what's come thus far this is
where we are in the game
uh what i have to do right now is kick
this ball because in the future what i'm
hoping is going to happen is
this person is going to receive the ball
and then they're going to kick it into
the net
right uh so if you break any of these
kind of these kinds of way of
experiencing the world into their
discrete moments
uh the whole process uh becomes
unclear to you you need to understand it
holistically
as a practice throughout time to
understand how it is that this person is
experiencing it
but one of the things that i think is
really innovative about what heidegger
does and really existential is
there have been other western
philosophers who've had holistic visions
of time
uh most of whom he doesn't particularly
like people like berks and uh
you may even add plato if you really
wanted to or or hegel
but he he actually insists that even
though time for us is ecstatic
what we still have to recognize is that
the ecstatic period of time
is finite and it's the fact that we
recognize that our period of time on
this earth is finite
that frames so many of our emotional
outlooks um
particularly our experience of things
like acts and being towards death
and so on right so you should probably
you know i might sit there and be
playing a soccer game
because i want to win okay but one of
the reasons why it is that i want to win
and i'm experiencing time holistically
in the moment of playing this game is
because i think to myself that
my life has a certain finite end to it
and becoming a really good soccer player
will help to give it a certain
significance
i don't think anyone's thinking of that
though the point is that you don't think
about that
well if you are a soccer player though
you might because that's what gives this
game significance and it's why you want
to win the game
it's why you don't just sit there
thinking to yourself like oh [ __ ] it you
know
whatever right it's just kidding all
right there's a couple points
i want to add in here i i want to add a
couple points in here because we
we got to go we got to talk about the
main distinction between being
singular and beings plural or obeying
right so so heidegger thinks that
metaphysics
and science for all time has been
focused on beings
and missed the question of being right
so beings
is like you could think of it as the
total collection of things that exist
those are beings and how do we get to
being from that do we just add it all up
and say well this is being
no that's not how we get to it because
everything that exists in some way has
being
but we don't encounter being directly we
don't encounter being the hammer exists
but we don't
counter its beingness we encounter
it as a being right and and the main way
that science or husserl even for that
matter
will encounter the hammer is what he
calls present at hand
for hand and height present at hand ness
you could call it so that's when it
appears for you
as an isolated object not in relation to
nothing else
it appears as an object and it has
properties
and it's it's self-sufficient what
heidegger wants to get to is a second
mode of being
what he calls zoohandan height which is
ready to hand
this second mode of being what he will
eventually describe as the being of
equipment
and the being of tools what we were
talking about you know the soccer player
the hammer and all that stuff but the
important point about these things
is that they exist in equipmental
totalities
they do not exist as singular objects
the hammer does not exist without the
nails to be hammered into
the nails and the hammer don't exist
without wood and houses to be built
right the carpenter doesn't exist
without all of this
equipmental totality that's the
important part about
zoohandin heights which is ready to hand
when you're just going about your day
and you're using objects right you use
your door to open it
you throw your blankets off in the
morning right those things don't appear
to you as
present at hand that's what we mean when
we say you don't have to think about it
i don't have to think about when i'm
even now today when i'm starting up my
computer i'm getting the podcast ready
like i'm not nothing's coming at me
present as hand
and i'm saying oh this is a substance
with these properties and i have to do
this
they're not self-sufficient substances
these things
exist in this mode of equipmental
totality
right so it's not just what the person
what it means to
the person that's wrong it's how it
exists
in a sort of totality and how it exists
in a sort of network
i like to think of it as a network or a
system of other things
that make that thing what it is too
right so they have again like i said the
hammer is not a hammer without nails the
nails and the hammer aren't anything
without wood and without houses to be
billed
without people who need shelter without
humans who need somewhere to dwell
right there's a sort of totality to
heidegger that he's trying to think of
as well
so it would be wrong just to think of it
as like
what it means to the design or like that
the design doesn't have to think about
it those are there
and of course like you can't have ready
to hand this without
present at handness there's in some way
they presuppose each other but but ready
to hand this doesn't depend
on something being
appearing to you present at hand so
that's the important point so all these
beings
we're thinking about if we get away from
this present at handness
where things appear as representations
as of objects and we get to this sort of
second mode of being
with this ready to hand this this
zoohand in height
right when we get there then we're
dealing with the world
then we're in there coping we are
embodied
and skilled beings who cope with the
world
and yeah in a way we don't have to think
about it i don't think that's the
decisive point whether or not we have to
think about it
when we use stuff right like if i'm
opening the door and suddenly someone
pushes on the other side and slams it
shut in my face
like okay something would come present
hand something would jump out at me then
and i have to step back and think
well what the hell happened this thing's
broken down it's not working as it
should
it's not allowing me to enter into my
other part of my house
something's gone wrong but that i don't
think the decisive question is whether
or not you have to think about it and i
don't think the decisive question here
is whether or not it
what it means to be a carpenter like to
be a carpenter
already implies this equipmental
totality that we can enter into
right i was going to say i agree with
you largely right but i do think that
there's a bit of a normative emphasis
here
that is implicit uh to go back to the
terms we have we used um
prior to the discussion within the
earlier heidegger but becomes a lot more
explicit later on right because what the
project in being in time kind of
presents itself as a purely
philosophical anthropology
right where it's just describing uh the
way that dassan apprehends the world
uh in its kind of historicity right um
but later on in later heidegger it's
pretty clear that he gives
a critical edge to this by saying that
one of the problems with the modern
epoch is precisely this regression
uh to an outlook that stresses thing
hood
uh beings over the question of being
right and this tends to
frame our relationship to the world in a
certain way that's deeply problematic
and this is where you get all of his
stuff on technology and the problems
with modernity
and while it's not as clearly explicated
in this book a lot of the stuff
a lot of these concerns are there uh
particularly i think when you look at
the later sections on
the problem of authenticity in the world
of the day or das mom
right i think the important difference
between being and beings
always remains though this is the other
word when you encounter
these words you'll you'll see ontology
which is the question of being
and you'll see antic which is beings
plural right so what heidegger will
later say
is what what gets lost is the
ontological difference what's the
difference between
beings as a sort of total of what exists
and being like the fact of existence
right and i think that's the reason that
it's hermeneutic and not descriptive is
because we encounter being
everywhere but it's sort of concealed
it's hidden
in beings right and in order to get to
it we have to perform
this sort of not a phenomenological
reduction
like hussera would call it the epikae or
the epice
where we get rid of our own biases and
we sort of step
out of the world and we're able to look
in from the outside
without any of those pesky sorts of
biases of the subject getting in our way
instead for heidegger that's impossible
you can't do that you're always that's
the
principle of throneness we were talking
about is is dozyne
is always there being that's why it's
dazing their being
he's always there or she is always there
i think heidegger only used he
among beings dealing with these beings
and then dazzan becomes a kind of third
type of being on top of
present at hand ready to hand and then
you have dazzin
and then later on in his career in the
40s and the 50s he comes up with
the work of art and the thingness maybe
you could think of those as fourth and
fifth types of being that he wants to
talk about
you know art as the presence of truth
and thing
meaning you know a gathering of
concerned beings around some kind of
thing that's why
you know you can go to iceland and you
can still find one in the government
buildings it's called the all thing
because that's what thing used to mean
it used to mean a gathering of people
over some issue that concerns everybody
right so he comes up with all these
differences of
modes of being and the important point
is i guess to get away from that sort of
present at handness where everything
appears as objects over and against some
kind of
subject and we've got to get away from
this way of thinking about things
and it's kind of fun because you can
look around in the world and you can
kind of do these thought experiments
with heidegger that you can't really do
with other philosophers in certain ways
right like how are you going to do a
thought experiment with like absolute
spirit it's like uh
what is that going to look like i don't
know start a revolution
yeah sure yeah go read marks that's what
it looks like but
i don't know when you're reading
heidegger it's kind of like yeah i'm i
am
thrown into this world and i'm coping
with
things using my inherent skills and
abilities
and sometimes things go wrong and they
appear present at hand to me but most of
the time
you know i'm not aware of it i'm wearing
my glasses i got my headphones on i'm
not thinking about those things
but the point is that glasses wouldn't
be glasses without lenses and lens
makers and
this whole equipmental totality and the
same can go with everything with glasses
and headphones and computers it's
it all exists in this sort of total and
that's that's sort of the important
point to get across
early on is i guess this difference as
well between being
and beings and you'll often see being
capitalized which is very silly because
it shouldn't be capitalized
the only reason it's capitalized is
because in german all nouns are
capitalized
so it's always capital beings would be
capitalized being would be capitalized
there's no difference there so the
english translation
kind of [ __ ] things up when it tries to
capitalize being
and or the point of distinction the
point about equipmentality though
like so um like you know my um my
recollection or my reading of it you
know is
yeah like that network kind of analysis
of things like there's
that definitely is an aspect of it but i
always remember the equipmentality being
much more related to just like
a connection to pro to like how does it
is a project right it's projecting
itself and like the equipmentality
is is used in in in assistance to dozens
projects right so like
when you're using a hammer to build a
house you're not thinking about the
hammer right as a as a
as a present at hand and by the way like
an interesting side note like
the stombau translation doesn't use
present at hand it uses
objectively there which i think is
trying to to more emphasize the way that
like
present at hand really means like you're
you're rendering it into like an
isolated object so like objectively
there like it's your app you're almost
abstracting it
you're turning it into like an abstract
entity rather than just something that
is being used
in your project like you're not thinking
about the hammer you're thinking about
building the house
or your next steps or what you're going
to do with your body to move in that way
and in a way you're not and then it's
like but but i guess the reason
this is this is what what you're
describing i'll just stop it is call is
what heidegger calls the in
order to that's what he does right
exactly so
let me just finish quickly so like i um
you know the equipment i guess like um i
yeah like the
the network analysis though to me seems
more like
turning what um equipment is
into a kind of objective of their object
when you start thinking about it in that
sense
like i guess because there's i guess i
want to make a distinction between like
that network analysis of how like
objects only exist in their relation to
other objects
which kind of seems like you're turning
it into an abstraction as opposed to
just dazai and doing its projects in the
world and it's not
thinking about how this book needed to
have like a like you know
a tree and lumber farms right it's just
doing its [ __ ] it's reading the book or
it's
so i don't know like is it like like
because that seems like an important i i
want to like
on what you're saying because um i i
actually tend to agree with you victor
although i also agree with eric that
like the more holistic way of reading
hardcore
uh is the way he articulated i think one
of the problems here is
actually um hermeneutic uh because
um when we read being in time i think it
is much more a book about
a certain kind of phenomenological
approach to the human being that does
stress
individuated projects in the world and
one's experience of time
which is probably why it's best
considered a work of existential
phenomenology that inspired many other
existential phenomenologists right
heidegger seems to back away
from this yeah and exactly the way eric
described starting from the 1930s going
forward
by stressing the kind of historicity and
embeddedness
of that sign in various ways of life
right
um yeah and this is where a lot of the
critique of modernity comes in and so on
and so forth
but it's just important to mention since
we seem to be stressing being in time
that i think the more appropriate one is
the one that uh interpretation of that
book specifically is the one that you're
giving
victor he also calls uh that objective
appearance you were saying sometimes
it's
translated as an occurrence as well
and the original like i think the best
translation that original machary
and robinson one they do call it ready
to hand
yeah present and with the hyphens yeah
it's funny in this one it's
it's ready to hand but then objectively
there it's the difference between
theoretical behavior and practical
behavior right when you're behaving
practically in the world you're like but
but you can't you got to be careful not
to import again metaphysical concepts
purpose
is a metaphysical concept that has no
place in heidegger's system you're not
using something to do
something in a sort of metaphysical
sense like the way heidegger is going to
put this
is that when whenever you like use a
hammer with a goal in mind
you subordinate your concern to a
in order to and you subordinate that
concern but that but then he makes a
distinction between an in order to
which kind of has a terminus in
something and then in order to
which is like just doing again
so he kind of makes all these
distinctions and he wants you to be
careful not to import these ideas of
like subjective desires
and goals and things we like literally
like project in the world
in the sense that like in the sense of
being a subject
talks a lot about those things projects
i mean i just want to like at least try
to
summarize because we're going into i
mean we'll put it up as is
but there's so much term dropping and i
know there has to be term dropping
but if we could stick to maybe a single
example and just carry it through
that might be a better way to do that i
was going to say maybe
what we could do just for the purposes
of being in time since that seems to be
the focus right now
is give our quick two like two
minute interpretation of what we think
the key points of the book are because i
think that would be where the
differences
in our interpretation of what's key
would come out most clearly because
i'm starting to get a sense that we all
have different approaches to it where
where i would stress like the kind of
existential interpretation of the book
uh i get the sense that eric might be a
little bit more inclined towards a
hermeneutic interpretation
and just because of the emphasis on the
subject it seems to me like victor
you're a little bit more prone to like
an existential phenomenological
interpretation
yeah fair to say for sure that's how i
learned it i learned it from somebody
who is also
an existential exactly so i mean i think
heidegger is phenomenological
existential okay well i'll open this up
i'll play the role of host and try to
open this up
um so heidegger brings up at one point
the definition of object and it's
interesting that we have
these words i don't know what they are
in german but in english his object
something that stands against he talks
about an object as if you
put it down in front of you and then are
banging your head into it
sort of yeah that happens that only
happens
in a world where usually things are
going wrong
um because we're so habituated we have
habits
about the world uh you can think about
when you're driving and you're
you can even though you're doing very
complex
actions with your body you can separate
your thoughts and then start daydreaming
about what you're gonna do later that
evening when you're driving even though
these actions are all very complicated
so they become incorporated and embodied
until
someone slams on their brakes in front
of you and now that car's an object and
now it becomes a problem so the object
it's a resistance to your experience but
please watch the road if you're
listening to this in the car
oh well i mean the fact that you can
listen to this in the car
sort of shows that embodied sense that
we're talking about with heidegger so
why don't we i mean we're actually all
saying similar things about the book
but coming at it from uh
the there's kind of like four heideggers
at least
and we're each kind of taking on one
height of their so the real height
please stand up right
yeah i mean the problem is we're just
except for the nazi heidegger
why don't we go around with a time limit
and
uh just try to get out the thing that
you think other people aren't getting
about what you're saying
or the thing that you think is most
important and we'll start with
that okay well i have to say just to
give my own kind of existential
interpretation of heidegger
um there's a lot that the other two are
going to cover that i think is very
important so i won't get into that
uh when i take away from it is this
right that heidegger has this very
profound interpretation of the human
experience of time
that he lifts in some way from sauron
kierkegaard
and nietzsche and others but reconciles
in a very innovative
and very systematic way that you don't
find in those earlier two authors right
and skip out a lot of the stuff but
basically there's this idea that we
inhabit and ex we have an ecstatic
relationship uh
to time as it appears at least to us
phenomenal logic can you explain
ecstatic you've said it a bunch of times
well the ecstatic idea of time that he
refers to is the fact that
we shouldn't conceive of time lineari as
linearly as a sequence of moments right
but rather as
essentially dassain being gripped or at
the epicenter of
the experience of the president and past
both tearing him or her
in different directions right because
our projects are in some sense
determined historically by
what it is that we've inherited from our
past and of course our objectives at any
given moment
and our hopes for the future right i'm
not using the technical terminology
right
the example i gave earlier is you know
the soccer player right who says sarah
thinks like well this is how the game
has gone thus far this is what i have to
do right now
this is what i hope to do with the game
going forward right uh but where this
becomes existential
is the fact of course that he says that
the signs ex
ecstatic experience of time is finite
right
it's going to come to an end because all
of us are being towards death in a
certain way
and rather than acknowledge that because
it generates a tremendous sense of angst
um or angst which is a term he picks up
from kierkegaard the concept of anxiety
uh we fall into the world of what he
calls das man or the they
as it's sometimes translated right which
is essentially a way of hiding from our
finitude
by essentially replicating the
activities of those that we see
all around us and because heidegger is
critical identity
he doesn't much like that and what he
says that we need to do instead
is to recognize the finite of time
that's available to us
and this is again a very niching idea so
that we can commit ourselves
authentically to projects
that can provide a sense of structural
unity to our lives
as a whole now what this project should
be he's never really very clear on
uh and i think it becomes kind of dark
later on when he
you think about the kind of projects he
thinks that uh we should commit
ourselves to
um but you know stripping away the
politics of this i think it's quite a
resonant idea
right and one of the ways that this was
expressed to me um
was again with reference to
kierkegaard's work uh where kierkegaard
would say
there are a lot of things that can give
your life a kind of epicenter of meaning
projects that are that important some of
them might be love
some of them might be philosophy some of
them might be aesthetic right
you know you really want to create the
great masterwork
of western poetry or western literature
and you always aspire towards that
but the problem of course is that these
will never fully come to fruition
because of the finitude of time
available to us
finite physical time not ecstatic time
all right victor
okay i agree with a lot of uh what matt
said i mean that's a part of that is a
lot of that is my takeaway as well like
i do tend to emphasize
um the way like the analysis of dozen
reveals the vulnerability of dazain or
like human beings
to fall into these kinds of like
conditions of bad faith where we ignore
um you know our condition is a finite
being
projected forward um and i think
you know the the the most important
aspect for me
is um you know the the the the upshot i
guess of it is authenticity which we
haven't really talked about so maybe
i'll just talk about that briefly like
for for heidegger authenticity is not
like some commonsensical
stupid pop cultural idea of being
authentic but it's actually just like
taking yourself taking seriously and
taking it up
in your uh in your being somehow as much
as possible
this existential structure of dozen
which is like the being towards death
um the way we're influenced and the way
we are always
um fleeing from um are our um
our like our destiny to to be being
towards death
and and the way we try to cover that
over with all these like everydayness
all these structures and ideas that we
have and we're trying to ignore that
and authenticity he uses this attitude
he calls it um
anticipatory resoluteness it's like this
attitude where does it
tries to take up this truth that we're
being towards death and that we're
always trying to flee from things and
hide things
with our like by falling prey to the das
mon which basically just means being
influenced by the crowd and
whatever the whatever the culture or
other people or your friends happen to
be saying
and i think i actually have like a quote
here that i think captures it
kind of nicely i've always liked this
one he's talking about how dozein
is always ambiguously there that is in
the public discloseness of being with
one another
which means being with other people like
the being influenced by the crowd and he
says
where the loudest idol talk and the most
inventive curiosity keeps
the business going where everything
happens in an everyday way
and basically nothing happens at all and
like this is in some ways exemplifying
the existential analysis of heidegger
where he's showing that
we're just getting our minds lost in
this nonsense and like gossip and all
these things and it's like
authentic i think authentic being for
him would be somehow
as much as possible pushing those things
aside
but i think one of the tragedies in in
in heidegger or the
the tragedy of the truth of dazzling is
that even heidegger himself says like
be like authenticity is an impossible
attitude
to keep going at all times because in
fact
the whole point of his analysis of
dazzling is that a fundamental feature
of dazan is that we're prone to fall
prey is that we're prone to like
be fall victim to the idol talk it's
impossible to not do that
that's gonna happen no matter what and
you will just have these little moments
these flashes of your anticipatory
resoluteness
where you can be authentic but it's a
moment and the rest of the time you're
gonna fall prey to the nonsense
and that to me is like the is the upshot
of being in town
just to riff on that for one second this
is i think why is gg used to say that
uh heidegger is one of the few
philosophers that you can find in the
20th century who
resolutely uh has no sense of humor
right because there's this very severe
attitude in them
yes anticipatory resolutionists about
you know the fundamental projects of
your existence and all this stuff and
you should
dismiss idol chatter and it's like well
you know a lot of humor is
idle chatter right exactly exactly and
actually just quickly
there's like one other quote which
captures this too it's like everyday
publicness
of the they which brings tranquilized
self-assurance
being at home with all its obviousness
into the average everydayness of dozyne
anxiety on the other hand fetches dazine
back out of its entangled absorption in
the world
every day familiarity collapses so this
is like describing
those little moments those ruptures
where you realize the anxiety
but i guess the anticipatory
resoluteness and real authenticity would
be in a way of taking up that anxiety
in a way that um i don't know gives you
some control over it for a moment at
least or makes you more aware of it in
this
deliberate way rather than just reacting
with
anxiety and dread i suppose
so i think uh eric and i should still
take our
lecture turn but i think this is quite
interesting because we do a lot of
leftist stuff and heidegger is almost
a crotchety sounding individualist
extolling you know ruggedness
and independence in the same way that
nietzsche or sartre do so i wondered if
you guys
see any tension in that this almost
anti-collective attitude and it's the
irony here
for me at least is the fact that he got
swept up into nazism after writing
these words well i don't think it's
particularly individualist in the way
that he interpreted it and this is
actually where i push back on this
because
you could find a radical reading of this
pretty easily right by saying that
and you know a lot of uh ideological
ideology theorists have right by saying
that
one of the reasons why it is that we
fall into the world of thus modern idol
chatter
is precisely because we're trying to
advance our social capital so the
fundamental problem is capitalism
and the kind of socioeconomic relations
that it establishes he doesn't go that
route right instead he turns to this
project of
collective national renewal uh and the
importance of participating in the
ongoing project of
germanification of europe uh and
i am we could talk about that more next
time if you want because i know we're
trying to put an x through his politics
right now
but i think that's really unfortunate uh
because i think there are much more
interesting
radical and leftist ways of interpreting
his work
that mark hughes engage in right i agree
i agree fundamentally with matt here i
think
i personally even have always read being
in time and as much as you know i've
been
um sympathetic to some [ __ ] from the
[ __ ] episode i still ultimately think
that being in time yeah
is pretty neutral like there's a way
there's totally a way of reading
um you know thrown-ness and and like
dasman and all that stuff in a very
progressive way
you could read like the fact that dazn
is so vulnerable to all these things
so subject to its condition as implying
i think some kind of
progressive politics you know because
it's like you you can't
blame you know if anything it's like
it's actually an argument against some
weird individualized
political philosophy that says people
have the power to pull themselves up
from their bootstraps because
this whole book is talking about how
[ __ ] impossible that is how like
how you're always going to fall prey to
[ __ ] and how like you like you're always
like um you know even even he says you
know authenticity is incredibly hard to
grasp so
it does actually um very much go against
this idea that we're like you know
rational agents who can just like to uh
take up our position and be responsible
right like i don't think that that
follows from this
all right um and and there's kind of an
analysis of power possible from that
perspective too but
absolutely i digress let's uh turn to
eric for his
lecture series um i think all i really
want to say is uh
heidegger comes up with the idea that um
existence precedes essence and
that basically means that popularized by
start but it's
it's it's inherent it's in being in time
you can uh
hit ctrl f and uh type it in there
but is it in existence with a k or
existence with an x
it's existential like the latin term oh
okay okay okay which
precedes essentia existential precedes
essentia which which basically means
that
that that the i mean
i guess it's not a bit there's nothing
to say basically about heidegger but but
existence preceding essence is
is the heart of of the phenomenological
method and
the ontology that he wants to bring out
is at essences when things have essences
you're identifying what makes things
what they are in the abstract
so you're not like you know you see a
hundred dogs out there for example and
you then you think
but what is the essence of the dog and
that's
and that well that okay you can you
think that way and that's perfectly fine
and you might you might make some
amazing discoveries
through thinking about like what is the
essence of the dog
the dog is not the cat therefore we can
make them into seeing eye dogs
so like you can maybe you can make some
but but really
i mean i i actually like the example
dogs because
humans have have uh evolved alongside
dogs for thousands and thousands of
years
and they they really are a fundamental
part of our being as as dazzin as well
and their their existence in that sense
of their just their being their their
i mean being in the
sense of ontology is not just a property
of beings because again then you're
sliding back into the uh
the metaphysical worldview with with
existence preceding essence
means that things are before they
are what they are you know they eke out
their existence in a certain way they
they cut their character into the into
the into being
before they become what they are in a
certain way you can't you can't say what
something is before it's going to appear
to you
and that and that's that's a kind of an
important idea i i think even kant says
the idea that being is not a property of
things
but for high degree he he makes a really
important point of that yeah and like
you said uh it's popularized by the
later phenomenal
phenomenological existentialists who
talk about the same sorts of things as
we we got to look at
what things are like in their being
before we know
what they are in the abstract in their
essence
and falls this is exactly why i think he
has such an influence on so many
post-structuralist like daredevil right
because there's this real critique of
representational thinking as saying you
know this simply
is what it is uh and we can define that
oh you're right
from other considerations yeah it
complicates the notion of identity
because we just think we know what
things are
when we look at them like i know the
essence of man i know the essence of
woman
and therefore like i can always identify
a man and a woman
but it kind of problematizes the idea of
an identity of what a thing is if it if
it's
existence precedes its essence if
it's being in the world precedes our
ability to say sort of what it is in
every case
then i i don't know how to say it like
what it seems to suggest is we need a
radical new approach to the way
we think about the world and i think
that's what heidegger is trying to bring
to us and
i mean that's i mean that's i'm saying
all i want to say there that's it that's
it
yeah all right my gosh
thank you look i don't i don't know if
you guys
i don't know what the edit sounds like
yet but
um if it sounds clean that's because i
have cut out all the places where we are
constantly interrupting each other
because
everyone seems to be really excited
about this topic even though we've only
covered
the first half of being in time and
sparsely
you wanted conflict be careful what you
wish for
[ __ ] well i've been sitting back but
i i notice that each of you are
interpreting this book kind of exactly
how i'd expect you to
so victor is taking the phenomenological
approach
sounds like you've read a lot of dreyfus
or
or whatever mary
and eric is harping on the divide
between subject and object
completely and matt is all about
historicity
historicity and projects well i'm using
a little harping
i'm gonna bring it i'll bring it to my
my zone because uh typically i don't
harp ever [ __ ] you you you hate the
subject
object eric you hate the subject object
divide more than any person i've ever
met
this is like your your passion project
anyway
we have not talked about language yet
heidegger has
a book called on the way to language a
book called poetry language thought an
essay called
on language and none of this really is
developed in being in time
but maybe i can give sort of a preview
of the direction that this could take
because the way i read heidegger is much
more hermeneutic in the sense that he's
the first person
and i think there's a technical uh
history of technics
argument to be made in here because
the microphone and the radio
kind of what we talked about last week
in a mcluhan sense came out
during heidegger's time so for me
an interesting thing that i haven't
studied yet and i'm saying it because uh
no one's really brought it up yet but
would be that text
seems transparent and especially texts
of philosophy seem to be about the thing
that they're about
rather than the process of reading or
rather the process of writing
and heidegger and darida following him
is one of the first
people to really notice how important
text
and writing is to the way that you see
the world
and particularly in terms of das sign
because what is more
present to hand and ready to hand at the
same time
than reading a book you all you you
forget that you're reading a book
um while you're reading it and it looks
like you're seeing this whole
invisible world of of beings even though
this is uh like a page in front of you
physically
a page in front of you so i think
we can talk about this a bit if you guys
are interested in this dimension but
uh to me heidegger's the first person
who
stopped seeing the text as transparent
stop seeing it as a window
and seeing it as this mechanism by which
the sign
uh discovers itself really
yeah and and in in terms of the world of
objects we're talking about hammers
we're talking about soccer
but in the world of design for him
text is like the most important object
that we could have
and i think if we were to develop
heidegger phenomenologically
the effect of phones keyboards computers
microphones all of this stuff
on the the life world would have a huge
output in terms of understanding like
what it does
to us and how we do it and how we are
along with
these objects and i like to say that
is that to say like uh like like at
the way the way that we talk about stuff
or how we talk about something
is at least as important as like what
we're talking about
yeah i guess that's the kind of point
there
pills yeah and i'd like to like uh
move forward from that a little bit just
to say that um first of all i think
wiccan science approach to language is
considerably more sophisticated than
heidegger's uh is but i think
that they get a lot of the same things
uh but rather than emphasizing the
things that i think they get the same
uh one of the things that i think is
really innovative about his approach to
language
is how he takes this almost
archaeological approach to it
in the sense that he says we tend to
objectify the world in a certain way
through the terms that we use
by saying as you know a lot of us have
put it and eric especially that
you know this is what it is because it
has this kind of essential quality to it
are there
essential features uh that we ascribe to
it uh and what he does really
innovatively and this is where his
philological background comes in is by
saying well
when we talk about things like
being all right sorry like thing hood uh
when we talk about things like poetry or
when we talk about
things like economy what are the roots
of those words
uh and he looks through their history
and says well
this determines a little bit about why
we ascribe this essence
to those words um in the way that we do
in certain practices
and it's not always clear to me how this
should be interpreted
because sometimes he's like refers to
the kind of
house of being that is language as a
gift that we inherit
and the kind of essentializations that
we make about uh the world and being as
a whole and the beings within it
uh as something we should be grateful
for right uh because how would we make
sense of the world without it
world without it right but at other
points it seems to be a lot more
critical of this uh particularly when it
comes to
the kind of way that we interpret
modernity uh because he sometimes will
say that well the kind
of essentialisms that we invoke when it
comes to
different objects in the world uh and
regarding them as things
uh and our language reflects this is the
base and it doesn't allow them to be
unconcealed
uh as what they are in the holism of
being
and this is precisely why we need to
problematize uh the way that we use
language right now in a way that only
things like poetry
uh are actually capable of uh and
when that kind of sense i think that
actually dara does very much his
uh spiritual heir in kind of poetically
deconstructing
uh the history of essentialisms that we
see
and the way that they're used in
everyday life right now and showcasing
how there were other possibilities that
might have been available to us
and might once again be available to us
if only we have the kind of
reflection to make them
bring them to consciousness in a way
that they weren't before language is the
house of being
in it we dwell yeah it's important
yeah i think i think another an
important image too to get out of it is
the tree of knowledge
that heidegger wants to go against you
can you can picture
the ground as what heidegger wants to
get to
and the tree of knowledge is metaphysics
and you have the trunk of the tree that
like one day humans planted the seed
and it grew into a tree and it became
the tree of knowledge and it was
its roots are in the ground and its
trunk and all that is like a
moral philosophy and the branches are
natural philosophy
and the sciences and and then the the
branches kind of
poke out but they never they never get
back to the ground they never
there's never a questioning of of what
they're grounded on
and in a sense heidegger wants to go
back down the tree
into the ground away from metaphysics
and towards the ground of being where
everything is where
what grounds everything is their being
and heidegger wants to get back to that
and the metaphysician could just say to
heidegger
oh well you're just doing the opposite
of what hegel is doing who's trying to
ascend to the heights
of metaphysics and you're just going
back down and then heidegger's rejoinder
to that
would be well if you see it that way
then you're still caught up in the
tradition of metaphysics and you're not
seeing things correctly
it just appears that just appears to be
what i'm doing but what i'm really doing
is trying to sweep away that entire tree
of knowledge and
i don't know what he wants to put in his
place not not probably not like a
rhizome or something like that like
delusion guterree do but
but he wants to sweep it around let's
get to analysis basically that's
actually yeah that's actually a part
that i always had trouble with higher
grades like what do you want to replace
it with like it's you know
i mean that's always what about the cost
man what about the cost
that's always that's always the question
i also i also do
i i think i don't afford to pull out all
these trees
it might be in being in time actually
because like ultimately like i don't
actually think he
he wants to like um you know totally
overturn all that stuff i think he just
wants it to be relabeled for what it is
right like
he would want science to just be like
relabeled that it's not doing what it
thinks it's doing it's like doing
something else which is like related to
like
dozens projects towards some like you
know
some end but it's not doing anything
fundamental yeah it's it's obviously
important i think you're
absolutely right about that but like in
some ways this
sort of metaphysical view that science
is grounded in
produces instrumentality and that's why
when he talks about technology
he talks about the way that science
treats the world as a standing reserve
and the way that everything becomes
object for us it has no
it has no i guess it has essence
so it's fungible it's replaceable in a
certain way so what what happens is you
treat the world
as a reserve out of which to
make things as
you know goals in your project like
you're importing this purpose
to humanity into your thinking and
you're saying well okay everything
should be serving that purpose so
you know animals are expendable the
environment is expendable the entire
earth is just a resource for us to use
in our projects
and you get this instrumentalism that
see i guess comes out really later in in
heidegger's work after the technology
question essay
and and it's it's actually led to some
to some kind of
environmental interpretations of
heidegger 2. everyone
keeps that in mind in the later
heidegger that he he doesn't like this
view of science based on techne
where it's just an instrumentalist kind
of thing he wants it again to be
to be consolidated to his
his phenomenological existentialism
where existence precedes essence
all right perfect place to end you you
circled back
exactly to the place where we started so
we have if we do an episode two that's
not a promise but if we do
heidegger part two then we can deal with
the language and the technology question
i think we should i mean we barely
scratched the surface of this one and i
think it's very clear that we have a lot
of enthusiasm
for the farm we might want to be more
organized next time maybe i feel like
the first half of this was like a little
bit of a mess and
yeah hopefully you do some editing there
pills but it's too instrumental to think
that we need a plan for these you know
yeah yeah all we're doing is creating a
clearing in the
in the minds of our listeners while
they're driving to
their instrumental maybe they'll enjoy
you yelling at us to stop uh to stop
interrupting each other
i'm gonna i'll maybe i'll leave one in
i'll leave one you'll
edit out the shrieks but it's like
it's whenever there's a lull then
everyone's like ah
and then whoever like talks loudest then
gets to keep going
i got the best mic so uh that's me
well anyway uh we got to get to
heidegger's cabin next time why did he
retreat from technology other than
getting kicked out of school because he
was a nazi
yeah why are there so many pictures of
him chopping wood and drawing he brought
her out of wells
what a freak yeah and who took those
pictures like he wouldn't use a
typewriter but he's like
hey bro take my picture i need i need to
show everybody how
earthy i am how can you do that
he calls his books like path marks and
you can just picture him walking around
the woods like oh
i'm a mountain man in the in the cuckoo
woods
do you guys know anything about buddhism
because there's actually a lot of
interesting connections to the fourfold
and
buddhism and apparently he had some
buddhist students as well i i know a
little bit but not very much you can
pick up like the dao da chang and
and find phrases that seem to be just
like imported directly into heidegger's
books so it's definitely important for
him
he might have plagiarized we don't know
anyway thanks victor
matt and eric uh thank you pills we hope
you guys uh thank you for your
wisdom and you're bringing us to this
great place i didn't i didn't do much
wisdom it was more like uh
babysitter today thank you authority
and your discipline your truly
foucault's wet dreams
thank you for your discipline leadership
i was i was shepherding being into
a comprehensible form for you thank you
for shepherding
really reminded me that we were in a
lockdown i had to shepherd your language
if if we were in person i could just
turn off your mic but
yeah all right thanks everybody hope you
liked it peace thank you
[Music]